This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. It's December 1954, around dinner time in Oak Park, Illinois, a suburb of Chicago. A group of Christmas carolers is performing before a huge crowd of about 200 people. It all seems perfectly normal. Except when you get closer, you can see something about the scene is off. Few people in the crowd appear to be in the Christmas spirit. Instead of cheering, they are taunting the carolers. Eventually, things reach such a frenzy that police are called in. The carolers are unfazed.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。时间是1954年12月，地点是芝加哥郊区伊利诺伊州橡树公园的晚餐时间。一群圣诞颂歌演唱者正在约200人的巨大人群前表演。这一切看起来都非常正常。但当你走近时，你会发现现场有些不对劲。人群中似乎没几个人有圣诞节的气氛。他们不仅没有欢呼，反而是在嘲弄演唱者。最终，事态变得如此疯狂，以至于警察都被叫来了。而演唱者们却泰然自若。
They keep singing their eyes on the sky. They're on the lookout for flying saucers, aliens who are going to transport them to another planet. One woman tells a newspaper reporter, we have been instructed to sing carols while we wait to be lifted up. You might think the characters were stupid or hopelessly gullible. Yet, the psychological phenomenon that had them in its grip turns out to be surprisingly common. You have certainly experienced it in your own life.
他们继续唱着歌，双眼望向天空。他们在寻找飞碟，寻找那些要把他们带到另一个星球的外星人。一位女士告诉报社记者，我们接到指示，要在等待被接走的同时唱颂歌。你可能会认为这些人很愚蠢或无可救药地轻信他人。然而，这种让他们深陷其中的心理现象却出奇地普遍。你肯定在自己的生活中也经历过。
Today we're going to tell you about the events that led up to that December evening in 1954 when flying saucers failed to appear over Oak Park. We're also going to tell you a second story, a modern story, about what happens in our minds when our biggest dreams fail to materialize. Several times I said, you know, my friends think that you may not be real. And his reaction was, why are people jealous of real love? And why aren't people happy for us? This week on Hidden Brain, the strange alchemy in our minds that makes it possible for us to live happily in an upside down world,
今天，我们将为你讲述导致1954年12月那个夜晚发生的一系列事件，当时飞碟没能出现在橡树公园上空。我们还要讲第二个故事，一个现代故事，讲述当我们的最大梦想未能实现时，我们的内心会发生什么。我好几次说，你知道，我的朋友们认为你可能不是真的。而他的反应是，为什么人们要嫉妒真正的爱情？为什么人们不为我们感到高兴？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，探讨我们内心那种奇怪的炼金术，它使我们能够在颠倒的世界中快乐地生活，
and believe that everyone else is wrong. A few months before the caroling incident, a psychologist at the University of Minnesota sat down to read the newspaper. Most of the stories weren't notable until he got to the back pages where he saw an article about a middle-aged suburbanite named Dorothy Martin. She claimed that extraterrestrials had chosen her as their messenger to planet Earth. The aliens, known as the Guardians, had told her a flood would engulf the west coast of North and South America from Seattle all the way to Chile in December 1954. from Seattle all the way to Chile in December 1954. The Guardian supposedly had the power to take control of Dorothy's hand and use it to write important teachings that she and all Earthlings needed to follow.
并相信其他人都是错的。在颂歌事件发生前几个月，明尼苏达大学的一位心理学家坐下来看报纸。大多数故事都不值得注意，直到他翻到后面的版面，看到一篇关于一位名叫多萝西·马丁的中年郊区居民的文章。她声称外星人选择了她作为他们向地球传递信息的信使。这些被称为“守护者”的外星人告诉她，1954年12月，一场洪水将淹没从西雅图一直到智利的北美和南美西海岸。守护者据称有能力控制多萝西的手，并用它写下她和所有地球人都需要遵循的重要教义。
The only way to be saved from the flood the Guardian said was to become spiritually pure. Most people probably laughed at the newspaper article and moved on, but Leon Festinger, the psychologist, was intrigued. He had been studying the idea that when something you believe is challenged, it creates a psychological tension or dissonance. In Dorothy Martin and her followers, Leon festering us a perfect real-life experiment to test his theory of cognitive dissonance. The flood would surely not occur.
守护者说，获救的唯一途径是变得精神纯洁。大多数人可能对这篇报纸文章笑了笑就过去了，但心理学家利昂·费斯廷格却很感兴趣。他一直在研究这样一个观点：当你的某种信念受到挑战时，会产生一种心理紧张或失调。在多萝西·马丁和她的追随者身上，利昂·费斯廷格看到了一个完美的现实生活实验，用来检验他的认知失调理论。洪水肯定不会发生。
How would believers respond when this happened? The theory of cognitive dissonance predicted that faced with unwelcome facts, the believers would come up with rationalizations that allowed them to believe that they were right and the world was wrong. The psychologists and his colleagues had covert observers infiltrate the group. Soon, they reported that Dorothy Martin's followers, who called themselves the Seekers, didn't just believe in an impending cataclysm. They were also convinced that they would be saved by aliens who would come and flying saucers to pick them up the night
当这种情况发生时，信徒们会作何反应？认知失调理论预测，面对不受欢迎的事实，信徒们会想出各种合理化解释，使他们能够相信自己是对的，而世界是错的。这位心理学家和他的同事让秘密观察员潜入了该组织。很快，他们报告说，多萝西·马丁的追随者（他们自称为“探索者”）不仅相信一场即将来临的灾难。他们还确信，他们会被乘坐飞碟前来的外星人救走，就在
before the flood engulfed the world. Your wives have been anything on earth. Use that intelligence. The seekers had plenty of company and they're fascination with aliens and UFOs. The obsession with other worldly creatures had reached something of a frenzy in 1950s America. Yes, it came from outer space to fill the world with theory. Imagine yourself as one of the crew of this faster than light spaceship of the world.
洪水淹没世界的前一天。你们的妻子在地球上做过任何事。利用那种智慧。探索者们对飞碟和外星人的痴迷并不孤单。对超自然生物的痴迷在20世纪50年代的美国达到了一种狂热的程度。是的，它来自外太空，用理论填满世界。想象你自己是这艘超光速宇宙飞船的船员之一。
In Washington, ghost-like objects dart across the radar screen at the CAA traffic controls and red light. Unlike most people fascinated by the idea of flying saucers, the seekers were deeply invested in their beliefs. Many quit their jobs, actively distance themselves from their loved ones, and drastically change their lifestyles. A man named Charles Lawhead was one of the most
在华盛顿，幽灵般的物体在民航局交通管制和红灯的雷达屏幕上飞速穿梭。与大多数对飞碟概念着迷的人不同，探索者们对他们的信仰投入极深。许多人辞去了工作，主动与亲人疏远，并彻底改变了生活方式。一个名叫查尔斯·劳黑德的人是该组织中最
devout members of the group. He and Dorothy Martin did many interviews about their beliefs. We were unable to track down audio recordings of those interviews. But throughout the story, you will hear voice actors reading comments that Dorothy Martin and Charles Lawhead made to newspaper reporters and to the researchers who infiltrated the group. They were certain that the end times were coming. It is an actual fact that the world isn't a mess, but the supreme being is going
虔诚的成员之一。他和多萝西·马丁就他们的信仰接受了多次采访。我们无法追踪到这些采访的录音。但在整个故事中，你将听到配音演员朗读多萝西·马丁和查尔斯·劳黑德对报社记者和潜入该组织的研究人员所说的话。他们确信世界末日即将来临。世界确实是一团糟，但至高无上的存在即将
to clean house. Charles Lawhead was a physician at Michigan State College. His views eventually made him something of a pariah. He was forced to resign from his job. His church community scorned his new beliefs. He and his wife spent so much time propagating the beliefs of the seekers that their children were very nearly taken away from them. that their children were very nearly taken away from them.
清理门户，这是一个事实。查尔斯·劳黑德是密歇根州立学院的一名医生。他的观点最终使他成为了某种被排斥的人。他被迫辞去了工作。他的教会社区鄙视他的新信仰。他和妻子花了太多时间传播探索者的信仰，以至于他们的孩子差点被带走。
We'll circle back in a bit to what happened to the seekers. But as I said at the top, we're going to tell you two stories in parallel today. I told you the story of the seekers looking from the outside in. From that perspective, a group of people waiting for flying saucers look foolish. But stories always look different when you truly understand people's dreams and motivations. Our second story today tries to do that. It looks at cognitive dissonance from the inside out. Hi, I am leaving a voice memo for Hidden Brain.
我们稍后再回到探索者们的遭遇。但正如我在开头所说，今天我们要并行讲述两个故事。我从外部视角为你讲述了探索者们等待飞碟的故事。从那个角度看，一群等待飞碟的人看起来很愚蠢。但当你真正理解人们的梦想和动机时，故事总是看起来不同。我们今天的第二个故事试图做到这一点。它从内部视角审视认知失调。嗨，我正在为《隐藏的大脑》留一段语音备忘录。
Some time ago we received a call from a listener in Arizona. I hope you find it interesting. Let me know what you think. Thank you. She asked to be identified as Liz. She told us that for a long time she had felt trapped in her marriage. I never felt we were really a team. I felt I was kind of on my own. A lot of the time I felt he made decisions that didn't include me and I have a high need to feel seen and heard. Liz felt her husband was a very smart man, but he didn't seem emotionally present. Often, when he was off making plans for the future, she would feel exasperated.
前段时间，我们接到了亚利桑那州一位听众的电话。希望你觉得它有趣。让我知道你的想法。谢谢。她要求被称为莉兹。她告诉我们，长期以来她一直感到被困在婚姻中。我从未觉得我们真的是一个团队。我觉得我大部分时间都是孤身一人。我感到他做的决定往往不包括我，而我非常需要被看见和被听见。莉兹觉得她丈夫是个非常聪明的人，但他似乎在情感上并不在场。通常，当他忙着为未来做计划时，她会感到恼火。
I remember thinking, just be quiet and change the diaper. You know, like be here now, don't be somewhere else. In 2018, after more than two decades of this chronic, low grade unhappiness, Liz felt she was ready for a change. Her kids were grown and out of the house. She was in her late 50s and felt an excitement about life stirring inside her. A youthful energy that felt increasingly out of step with her husband. Where she valued spontaneity, he craved order. I was unhappy enough to feel like I needed to do something about it. She sought a divorce and got it. It was her first time being single in a quarter century. She felt
我记得当时想，安静点，去换尿布吧。你知道，就像活在当下，别去别的地方。2018年，在经历了二十多年这种慢性的、低程度的不快乐之后，莉兹觉得她准备好做出改变了。她的孩子们已经长大并离开了家。她快60岁了，感到内心有一种对生活的热情在涌动。一种年轻的活力，与她丈夫的步调越来越不一致。她重视自发性，而他渴望秩序。我当时很不快乐，觉得我需要为此做点什么。她寻求离婚并成功了。这是她四分之一个世纪以来第一次单身。她感到
disoriented and a little scared, but she was also consumed with a searing desire. She wanted to be with someone who got her, really got her. So she sat down and wrote out the quality she wanted in a romantic partner. I asked her if she would go find the list and read it to me. Okay, I'm back. The first thing I wrote was emotionally alive and available, evolved, attractive, open, wanting to bond in Bia United Front. And in some ways I'm hearing that these were also things that may have been lacking in your previous life. And that's partly why you were reminding yourself that these were things that were important to you.
迷茫和一点害怕，但她也被一种强烈的渴望所吞噬。她想和一个真正懂她、完全懂她的人在一起。于是她坐下来，写下了她想要的浪漫伴侣的品质。我问她是否可以把那张清单找出来读给我听。好的，我回来了。我写的第一件事是情感上活跃且可得、成熟、有吸引力、开放、想要建立统一战线。在某种程度上，我听出这些也是你前一段生活中可能缺失的东西。这部分就是为什么你在提醒自己这些对你很重要。
Yes. I think the most salient part was emotionally available and emotionally intelligent. One morning, after a year of reflection and gathering up the pieces of her life, Liz felt she was ready to start what she called her second job, finding her soulmate. She created a profile on online dating sites. I took a photograph of me,
是的。我认为最突出的部分是情感上可得和情感上聪明。一天早上，在经过一年的反思和整理生活的碎片后，莉兹觉得她准备好开始她所谓的第二份工作了：寻找她的灵魂伴侣。她在在线约会网站上创建了一个个人资料。我拍了一张我的照片，
like a sailor looking, putting my hand over my brow, like looking into the distance, looking for something. Over the next month, she chatted with men on the apps, trying to sass out which ones had the qualities on her list. For the most part, no one stood out. And then, one morning in July, she came across a new profile. A European man named Sergio. He was a very handsome man with little round glasses
就像水手一样，把手放在额头上，向远处眺望，寻找着什么。接下来的一个月里，她在应用程序上与男人们聊天，试图摸清哪些人具备她清单上的品质。大多数情况下，没有人脱颖而出。然后，七月的一个早晨，她看到了一个新的个人资料。一个名叫塞尔吉奥的欧洲男人。他是一个非常英俊的男人，戴着一副小圆眼镜，
that looked sophisticated, wore scarves in some of his pictures. The photographs showed him with a bright smile. He had a gap between his front teeth, which I found adorable. Sergio was a few years older than her. His profile said that he was an engineer who liked museums, taking long walks, and going to the movies. He looked perfect. Even more perfect, when she messaged him, he messaged her right back.
看起来很精致，有些照片里还戴着围巾。照片显示他带着灿烂的笑容。他的门牙之间有缝隙，我觉得这很可爱。塞尔吉奥比她大几岁。他的个人资料说他是一名工程师，喜欢博物馆、长途散步和看电影。他看起来很完美。更完美的是，当她给他发信息时，他立刻就回复了。
It was like, you know, the equivalent of being at a bar and the guy saying, let's get out of here. It was exactly the same feeling, like, ooo, okay, let's do it. Liz knew there was little chance. Sergio would be whisking her anywhere anytime soon. He lived in Italy, but she was undeturbed. She felt a spark. The kind of spark she had not felt in a long, long time. Liz and Sergio quickly moved to chatting on WhatsApp.
这就像，你知道，相当于在酒吧里，那个男人说，我们离开这里吧。感觉完全一样，就像，噢，好吧，我们走吧。莉兹知道塞尔吉奥很快带她去任何地方的可能性很小。他住在意大利，但她并没有感到不安。她感觉到了一种火花。那种她已经很久很久没有感觉到的火花。莉兹和塞尔吉奥很快转到了WhatsApp上聊天。
Liz remembers the afternoon. They had their first heart to heart. I was about to start a hike near my house. There's a nice uphill and then a beautiful long path among Pandoro Sapines. And then you can walk for miles and miles. As she started her hike, she typed a message on WhatsApp and hit send. I just said, hi, it's me and he said, oh, wonderful. I'm so happy to have the chance to talk with you and get to know you a little bit better away from the dating site.
莉兹记得那个下午。他们进行了第一次交心。我正准备在我家附近开始徒步旅行。那里有一段不错的上坡路，然后是一条美丽的、穿过潘多罗松树林的长路。然后你可以走上好几英里。当她开始徒步时，她在WhatsApp上打了一条信息并点击发送。我只是说，嗨，是我，他说，噢，太棒了。我很高兴有机会和你交谈，并在约会网站之外更好地了解你。
She typed as she walked up the hill, telling him where she was. He asked for a picture. I sent him the picture of me wearing my big straw hat and he said, oh you're so beautiful. Liz had been waiting a long time for a conversation like this. She told Sergio, what my life was like, what I was looking for, how lonely I felt, how I longed for our connection, how I wanted to be seen by someone.
她一边上山一边打字，告诉他她在哪里。他要了一张照片。我发给他一张我戴着大草帽的照片，他说，噢，你太美了。莉兹已经等待这样的对话很久了。她告诉塞尔吉奥，我的生活是什么样的，我在寻找什么，我感到多么孤独，我多么渴望我们的联系，我多么想被某人看见。
Sergio took in everything. He was understanding, he was empathetic, he was a fantastic listener. He affirmed a lot of the things I spoke about about my loneliness or sadness, he said, wow, I'm really sorry to hear this has happened to you. I can't imagine why someone would let you go. I almost wanted to stop and say, tell me more. Tell me more about why you like me so much. And tell me what was going through
塞尔吉奥接受了一切。他很善解人意，他很有同理心，他是一个出色的倾听者。他肯定了我所说的关于孤独或悲伤的很多事情，他说，哇，听到你经历这些我真的很抱歉。我无法想象为什么有人会放开你。我几乎想停下来对他说，多告诉我一些。多告诉我一些为什么你这么喜欢我。并告诉我当时你心里在想什么，
your heart at that point because you're going on this beautiful walk You're talking to this person on WhatsApp He's saying very nice things and very sweet things to you. What's going through your heart? What do you feel? I'm feeling relief. I'm feeling healing I'm feeling good about myself I'm feeling beautiful. I'm feeling sexy. I'm feeling good about myself. I'm feeling beautiful. I'm feeling sexy.
因为你正在进行这次美丽的散步，你正在WhatsApp上和这个人交谈，他在对你说非常好的、非常甜美的话。你心里在想什么？你感觉到了什么？我感到解脱。我感到治愈。我对自己感觉很好。我感到自己很美。我感到自己很性感。我对自己感觉很好。我感到自己很美。我感到自己很性感。
I'm feeling seen, really. I'm feeling heard. Sergio wasn't just a good listener. He was also open about himself. He seemed to be in touch with his emotions. He talked about his own divorce, his son, about growing up in Sweden and moving to Italy as a young man. Some of his writing was interesting.
我真的感到被看见了。我感到被听见了。塞尔吉奥不仅是一个好的倾听者。他也对自己很坦诚。他似乎与自己的情绪保持着联系。他谈到了自己的离婚、他的儿子，以及在瑞典长大并在年轻时搬到意大利的经历。他写的一些东西很有趣。
It was definitely not perfect English. His grammar and his sentence structure was sometimes endearingly foreign. Liz liked that they were both bicultural. She had grown up in Mexico and moved to the United States in her early 20s. Liz and Sergio messaged back and forth for hours that day until it was time for Liz to go to bed. The moment she woke up the next morning, she checked her phone.
那绝对不是完美的英语。他的语法和句子结构有时带有可爱的异国情调。莉兹喜欢他们都是双重文化背景。她在墨西哥长大，20岁出头时搬到了美国。莉兹和塞尔吉奥那天来来回回发了几个小时的信息，直到莉兹该睡觉了。第二天早上她醒来的那一刻，她检查了手机。
There were no new notifications, but then her phone pinged. He sent me a message saying, good morning, beautiful. And I felt, oh, this was not a dream, and he's still here. He's still pursuing me. Soon, their WhatsApp messages became a fixture of her daily life. And then I start figuring out a rhythm of when he's available or when he's not at work, and we start conversing more during those times.
没有新的通知，但随后她的手机响了。他发给我一条信息说，早上好，美丽的。我感觉，噢，这不是梦，他还在。他还在追求我。很快，他们的WhatsApp信息成了她日常生活的一部分。然后我开始摸索他什么时候有空，什么时候不在工作，我们开始在那些时间里进行更多的交流。
Sergio explained his complex relationship with his ex, and his sadness about not being allowed to see his teenage son, as often as he would like. He shared how he had distracted himself by helping underprivileged kids. He had even taken in a young woman from Africa who had fled to Italy as a refugee. That was another tug to my heart. His man had integrity, he was kind,
塞尔吉奥解释了他与前任之间复杂的关系，以及因为不能像他希望的那样经常见到十几岁的儿子而感到的悲伤。他分享了他是如何通过帮助贫困儿童来分散注意力的。他甚至收留了一位从非洲逃到意大利的难民年轻女性。这又触动了我的心。这个男人有正直的品格，他很善良，
he shared what he had with other people and really cared for, for someone enough to really help. It was hard for me to believe that this person was as interested in me as he was and as consistent and as devoted to daily communication. He made me feel good about myself. He was complimentary. He listened. He asked questions.
他与他人分享他所拥有的，并且真的关心某人，足以真正去帮助。我很难相信这个人像他表现的那样对我感兴趣，并且如此持续、如此致力于每天的沟通。他让我对自己感觉很好。他很会赞美。他倾听。他提出问题。
They hadn't spoken on the phone yet, but after a week, they found a time to talk. He had a low, very quiet voice, with an accent that I didn't recognize as Italian per se, but it was definitely European sounding, and I was a little nervous, a little excited. I was still incredulous about why me, and I teased them about him, you know, you should check out other women before you settle on me. And I remember him saying, no, I know what I want. It felt so easy, so effortless.
他们还没有通过电话，但一周后，他们找到了通话的时间。他的声音很低、很安静，带着一种我认不出是意大利语的口音，但绝对听起来是欧洲口音，我有点紧张，有点兴奋。我仍然怀疑为什么是我，我拿他开玩笑，你知道，你应该在决定和我在一起之前看看其他女人。我记得他说，不，我知道我想要什么。感觉太容易了，太轻松了。
This was how love was supposed to be, let's start. He was the one that said the L word first. And that just made my life full and my heart full. And I reciprocated. I fell in love with this man deeply. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Before we continue our story of Liz and Sergio's romance, we're going to wind the clock back
这就是爱情本该有的样子，让我们开始吧。是他先说了那个“爱”字。那让我的生活变得充实，我的心也变得充实。我也做出了回应。我深深地爱上了这个男人。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。在我们继续讲述莉兹和塞尔吉奥的浪漫故事之前，我们要再次把时钟拨回
again to 1954. No flying saucers emerged from the sky over the Oak Park carolers that December. It was disappointing, but the group knew they didn't always understand the ways of the powerful spirits communicating with Dorothy Martin. A few months earlier, in July 1954, Dorothy Martin told the group that the guardians had instructed them to drive to an army base and park on the outskirts.
1954年。那个十二月，橡树公园的颂歌演唱者上方的天空中没有出现飞碟。这令人失望，但该组织知道他们并不总是能理解与多萝西·马丁交流的强大灵魂的方式。几个月前，即1954年7月，多萝西·马丁告诉该组织，守护者指示他们开车去一个陆军基地，并停在郊外。
Charles Lawhead and a few other seekers joined her. She later described the experience to the researchers who had infiltrated the group. We didn't know what we were looking for. We were looking for saucers. As we stood there eating our lunch from the back of the car, just standing there in the fields alongside the road and looking up at the sky,
查尔斯·劳黑德和其他几位探索者加入了她。她后来向潜入该组织的研究人员描述了这次经历。我们不知道我们在寻找什么。我们在寻找飞碟。当我们站在那里从车后吃午饭时，只是站在路边的田野里，抬头看着天空，
we must have looked very silly. On another location, the sea cars were instructed to wait and door these back yard. It was winter time, so cold they had to stop their feet against the frozen ground to keep their toes from going numb. Again, no extraterrestrials came to save them. Each time the flying saucers failed to show up, Dorothy got a message from the guardians explaining their absence.
我们一定看起来很傻。在另一个地点，探索者们被指示在多萝西的后院等待。那是冬天，天气很冷，他们不得不跺着脚踩在冰冻的地面上，以防脚趾冻僵。同样，没有外星人来救他们。每次飞碟没能出现，多萝西都会收到守护者发来的解释他们缺席的信息。
It wasn't time. The journey had been delayed. They were putting the believers through training to prepare for the real deal. We don't have to understand everything. The plan has never gone astray. We don't know what the plan is, but it has never gone astray. plan is, but it has never gone astray. On the day before the predicted flood was to strike the earth, Charles Lawhead and the rest of the believers, sat in Dorothy Martin's living room, eyes glued to the clock. Tension filled the room. Eventually, the clock struck midnight.
时间还没到。旅程被推迟了。他们正在对信徒进行训练，为真正的行动做准备。我们不必理解一切。计划从未偏离。我们不知道计划是什么，但它从未偏离。在预言洪水袭击地球的前一天，查尔斯·劳黑德和其他信徒坐在多萝西·马丁的客厅里，眼睛盯着时钟。房间里充满了紧张气氛。最终，时钟敲响了午夜。
The day of cataclysm had come, but the guardians did not arrive. The group turned manic. They frantically began trying to reinterpret the guardians' messages, sure that they had somehow misunderstood the warning. The only possibility they didn't consider was that they had been wrong about the whole thing. Charles Lawhead explained why, and in so doing, offered the most succinct explanation of how cognitive dissonance works.
灾难之日已经到来，但守护者没有出现。该组织变得狂躁起来。他们疯狂地开始试图重新解读守护者的信息，确信他们以某种方式误解了警告。他们唯一没有考虑的可能性是，他们对整件事都搞错了。查尔斯·劳黑德解释了原因，并以此提供了关于认知失调如何运作的最简洁的解释。
I've had to go a long way. I've given up just about everything. I've cut every tie. I've burned every bridge. I've turned my back on the world. I can't afford to doubt. I have to believe. More than 50 years later, Liz was feeling something similar. She was in the very earliest stages of what the seekers were going through. But already, she was finding it easy to see only what she wanted to see, and here, only what she wanted to hear.
我不得不走很远的路。我放弃了几乎所有东西。我切断了每一条联系。我烧毁了每一座桥梁。我背弃了世界。我不能怀疑。我必须相信。50多年后，莉兹也有类似的感觉。她正处于探索者们所经历的最初阶段。但她已经发现，只看她想看的东西，只听她想听的东西，是多么容易。
Sergio and Liz had not yet talked face to face, only over text or on the phone. So she suggested a video chat. I remember him saying, let me see what I can do. I'm having a lot of issues with the internet. I live in an old neighborhood in Florence and we've been having a lot of problems. But let me get back to you on that, okay? And I would be thinking, okay, it sounds like a fair reason not to look at each other. Instead of thinking about why Sergio wasn't hopping on a video call with her, Liz found it more pleasant to imagine him meandering
塞尔吉奥和莉兹还没有面对面交谈过，只是通过短信或电话。所以她建议视频聊天。我记得他说，让我看看我能做什么。我的互联网有很多问题。我住在佛罗伦萨的一个老街区，我们一直有很多问题。但让我回头再告诉你，好吗？我会想，好吧，这听起来是一个不看对方的合理理由。莉兹没有去想为什么塞尔吉奥不和她进行视频通话，而是觉得想象他在佛罗伦萨狭窄的街道上漫步
along the narrow streets of Florence. At one point, she asked him for a picture of the view from his apartment, hoping it would match her fantasies. But when she got the picture, it was like a empty lot. There were no cars. It was just like concrete
更令人愉快。有一次，她让他拍一张他公寓窗外的景色，希望它能符合她的幻想。但当她收到照片时，那就像一块空地。没有车。就像混凝土，
and you could see in the distance trees and and homes. It looked like it was taken from the second or third floor. Looking down. I thought it was a very strange way of showcasing where he was. But I didn't say anything, I didn't pursue it. About a month into their relationship, Sergio shared some news. He was going to Turkey on a business trip. He tells me, I'm really excited. I am competing for a huge, huge contract with the government of Turkey. If this goes through, I'll be able to land a multi-million dollar contract
你可以看到远处的树木和房屋。看起来像是从二楼或三楼拍的。向下看。我觉得这是一种展示他所在位置的非常奇怪的方式。但我什么也没说，我没有追问。在他们建立关系大约一个月后，塞尔吉奥分享了一些消息。他要去土耳其出差。他告诉我，我真的很兴奋。我正在为土耳其政府的一个巨大的、巨大的合同进行竞争。如果成功了，我将能够获得一份数百万美元的合同，
for telecommunication to wire part of the country. The trip sounded so important and meaningful. Liz felt proud to be in love with such a motivated man. And a couple days later, he says, I got the contract. I received the contract. I am so excited. It's going to be huge. They're going to pay me all this money. Here's a picture of a ship, like a cargo ship,
用于电信，为该国部分地区铺设线路。这次旅行听起来如此重要且有意义。莉兹为能爱上这样一个有进取心的男人而感到自豪。几天后，他说，我拿到了合同。我收到了合同。我太兴奋了。这会是巨大的。他们会付给我这么多钱。这是一张船的照片，就像一艘货船，
that's going to be transporting all the hardware from Italy to Turkey. And I just wanted to show you what I started putting together. Sergio sounded like a man who knew how to get things done. Plus, he was deploying his talents not just to make money, but to do good in the world. Liz was full of admiration. And then? Suddenly the conversation shifts. He says, oh no.
它将把所有的硬件从意大利运往土耳其。我只是想让你看看我开始准备的东西。塞尔吉奥听起来像是一个知道如何把事情办成的人。此外，他不仅在利用自己的才能赚钱，还在为世界做好事。莉兹充满了钦佩。然后呢？谈话突然转变了。他说，噢，不。
Oh my gosh. I just got a message that tells me that there's taxes that I will not be able to cover. What am I gonna do? They're not going to let me not pay the taxes. I am going to be really sad. It looks like I'm going to lose the contract. What a missed opportunity.
噢，天哪。我刚收到一条信息，告诉我有些税款我无法支付。我该怎么办？他们不会让我不交税的。我会非常难过的。看起来我要失去这份合同了。多么错失的机会啊。
Liz's heart melted. She couldn't bear the idea of this lovely man losing out on his dream. I say, please let me help you come up with the money that you're short. And he said, oh no, I couldn't, I couldn't ask you to do that. No, no. And so I insist. I say, I can help you and you can pay me back.
莉兹的心融化了。她无法忍受这个可爱的男人失去梦想的想法。我说，请让我帮你凑齐你缺少的钱。他说，噢，不，我不能，我不能要求你这样做。不，不。于是我坚持。我说，我可以帮你，你可以还给我。
He gets quiet and eventually he says, okay. Liz pulled the money out of her savings account and wired it to Sergio. She drained nearly two thirds of her savings, but that seemed like a small price to pay for the joy that Sergio had brought to her life. A few weeks after she transferred the money, Liz went to Colorado to spend some time with two of her closest friends, Sisters Diedra and Shelley. Liz couldn't wait to tell them about her new romance. The sisters had known about her unhappiness throughout her marriage, and supported her through
他安静下来，最终他说，好的。莉兹从她的储蓄账户里取出了钱，汇给了塞尔吉奥。她花光了近三分之二的储蓄，但这对于塞尔吉奥带给她生活的快乐来说，似乎是一个很小的代价。在她汇款几周后，莉兹去了科罗拉多州，和她最亲密的两个朋友，迪德拉和雪莉姐妹待在一起。莉兹迫不及待地想告诉她们她的新恋情。姐妹俩在她的整个婚姻期间都知道她的不快乐，并支持她度过了
her divorce. Shelly still remembers how happy Liz sounded. She was feeling so much joy, so much love. It was just bubbling out of her and filled the entire room. And it's a big room with a high ceiling. It felt like the entire room was buzzing with her excitement. But almost from the start, Dydro and Shelley saw something that Liz could not. This was simply too good to be true. How could this really be?
她的离婚。雪莉仍然记得莉兹听起来有多快乐。她感到如此多的快乐，如此多的爱。它只是从她身上冒出来，填满了整个房间。那是一个天花板很高的大房间。感觉整个房间都在随着她的兴奋而嗡嗡作响。但几乎从一开始，迪德拉和雪莉就看到了莉兹看不到的东西。这简直好得令人难以置信。这怎么可能是真的？
She had never met this man. He lived in Italy. She had barely even talked with him on the phone. Shelley and Deidre shot uneasy glances at one another. By the end of the evening, they left Liz typing away at her phone, talking to Sergio. Shelley vividly remembers what happened the next morning. I remember Deidre coming down the stairs looking tired and a bit frazzled, she was absolutely certain that this was a scam and that Liz did not realize it and was being completely taken. Deidre had stayed up all night researching romance camps. She had come across an FBI page that
她从未见过这个男人。他住在意大利。她甚至几乎没在电话里和他交谈过。雪莉和迪德拉不安地互看了一眼。那天晚上结束时，她们留下莉兹在手机上打字，和塞尔吉奥聊天。雪莉生动地记得第二天早上发生了什么。我记得迪德拉走下楼梯，看起来很累，有点心烦意乱，她绝对肯定这是一个骗局，而莉兹没有意识到，正被完全利用。迪德拉整晚都在研究浪漫骗局。她偶然发现了一个FBI页面，
described the typical tactics con artist's use to hook their victims. Deidre said when Liz was describing her relationship with Sergio, all of that precisely fit the FBI description of how these scammers work. Down to the last details of his profession, his having a son and the way he was traveling. And she said, I feel like this is a dangerous situation that is really going to hurt her. Shelley and Diedra knew they had to nip things in the bud. Liz was a very smart, thoughtful woman.
描述了骗子用来诱骗受害者的典型策略。迪德拉说，当莉兹描述她与塞尔吉奥的关系时，所有这些都完全符合FBI对这些骗子如何运作的描述。细致到他的职业、他有一个儿子以及他旅行方式的每一个细节。她说，我觉得这是一个危险的情况，真的会伤害她。雪莉和迪德拉知道她们必须防患于未然。莉兹是一个非常聪明、有思想的女人。
She had two masters degrees. They would present the facts to her, and she would realize she was making a mistake. Shelly took the lead. I said, I know that it may be difficult for you to believe it, but I just want you to be aware that what you've described to us fits the profile of a scammer. And I asked her if she would promise me that she would not send any money to him unless she talked to one of us first and talked it through and that, you know, we knew what she was doing. I asked Shelley what Liz said in response. She said, I believe that Sergio is who he says he is.
她有两个硕士学位。她们会把事实摆在她面前，她会意识到自己犯了一个错误。雪莉带头。我说，我知道这可能很难让你相信，但我只是想让你知道，你向我们描述的情况符合骗子的特征。我问她是否能答应我，在没有先和我们其中一人交谈并讨论清楚之前，不要给他汇任何钱，你知道，我们要知道她在做什么。我问雪莉莉兹是怎么回应的。她说，我相信塞尔吉奥就是他说的那个人。
I trust my own instincts and I am not interested in what someone else thinks. When Shelley and Deidre questioned if Sergio was real, Liz did not feel gratitude. She felt hurt. Her friends knew how unhappy she had been. Why were they trying to rob her of happiness? Rather than share further confidences about Sergio with her friends, Liz started to share confidences about her friends with Sergio. Several times I said, you know, my friends several times I said you know my friends think that you may not be real and my friends have told me to stop communicating with you. Sergio did not respond with anger. He did not respond with defensiveness. He
我相信我自己的直觉，我对别人怎么想不感兴趣。当雪莉和迪德拉质疑塞尔吉奥是否真实时，莉兹并没有感到感激。她感到受伤。她的朋友们知道她曾经有多么不快乐。为什么她们要试图剥夺她的幸福？莉兹没有与朋友分享更多关于塞尔吉奥的秘密，而是开始与塞尔吉奥分享关于朋友的秘密。我好几次说，你知道，我的朋友们认为你可能不是真的，我的朋友们告诉我停止和你交流。塞尔吉奥没有愤怒地回应。他没有防御性地回应。他
responded with sadness. His reaction was, why are people jealous of real love? Why are people unwilling to let people be and enjoy what they have? Why aren't people happy for us? It reinforced what Liz was feeling. I think at times I felt like they were raining on my parade. Liz also told herself that Shelley and Diedra and her other friends did not know Sergio like she knew Sergio. They had not heard the quiet conviction in his voice. They
悲伤地回应。他的反应是，为什么人们要嫉妒真正的爱情？为什么人们不愿意让别人顺其自然，享受他们所拥有的？为什么人们不为我们感到高兴？这加强了莉兹的感受。我想有时我觉得她们在扫我的兴。莉兹也告诉自己，雪莉、迪德拉和她的其他朋友并不像她了解塞尔吉奥那样了解他。她们没有听到他声音中那种安静的信念。她们
hadn't felt his kindness. They also didn't know something else. Sergio had told her he was coming to visit her for her birthday. Would a fictitious boyfriend do that? Liz could hardly wait. After months of texting and phone calls, the day of Sergio's flight arrived. He sent her a message, telling her he was on his way to the airport. Like the star of a Hollywood romantic drama, Liz jumped in her car and buzzing with excitement drove several hours to Phoenix International Airport.
没有感受到他的善良。她们还不知道另一件事。塞尔吉奥告诉她，他要来看她过生日。一个虚构的男朋友会那样做吗？莉兹几乎等不及了。经过几个月的短信和电话，塞尔吉奥的航班到达之日终于到了。他给她发了一条信息，告诉她他正在去机场的路上。就像好莱坞浪漫剧的主角一样，莉兹跳进车里，带着兴奋，开车几个小时去了凤凰城国际机场。
I am bursting at the seams. I am so excited. I have plans, I have dreams. I can't wait to see them in person. I'm just high as a kite. I am flying. What did you imagine you would do when you first saw him? Would you rush into his arms?
我激动得快要炸开了。我太兴奋了。我有计划，我有梦想。我迫不及待地想亲自见到他。我简直高兴得飞起来了。我正在飞。你想象你第一次见到他时会做什么？你会冲进他的怀抱吗？
Would you hug him? What was that moment like in your head? Oh, yeah. I was sure we were going to look into each other's eyes and then kiss passionately. Once in the terminal, she couldn't keep her eyes off the screen displaying flight arrivals. I am pacing, I am excited. I have that nervous energy.
你会拥抱他吗？在你脑海中，那一刻是什么样的？噢，是的。我确信我们会注视着对方的眼睛，然后深情地接吻。进入航站楼后，她的眼睛无法离开显示航班到达信息的屏幕。我来回踱步，我很兴奋。我有那种紧张的能量。
Finally, Sergio's flight landed. People began to filter into baggage claim. Liz saw families reuniting. She heard couples speaking in Italian. And I wait and I wait and I wait and nobody shows up that looks like the person I'm waiting for. Like Sergio. Yeah. She called Sergio over and over, but he didn't answer. I remember thinking, this doesn't make any sense. Like, what could have happened that he's not communicating with me?
终于，塞尔吉奥的航班降落了。人们开始涌入行李提取处。莉兹看到家人们团聚。她听到情侣们用意大利语交谈。我等啊等，等啊等，没有人出现，看起来像我在等的那个人。就像塞尔吉奥。是的。她一遍又一遍地给塞尔吉奥打电话，但他没有接。我记得当时想，这根本说不通。就像，发生了什么事，他为什么不和我交流？
He's not on the plane. Liz was experiencing something that Leon Festinger called Disconfirmation. Disconfirmation is what happens when a belief is challenged by powerful evidence. In this case, Sergio not showing up at the airport challenged Liz's belief that Sergio was telling the truth about who he was.
他不在飞机上。莉兹正在经历利昂·费斯廷格所说的“不确认”。不确认是当信念受到有力证据挑战时发生的情况。在这种情况下，塞尔吉奥没有出现在机场，挑战了莉兹关于塞尔吉奥对他身份的陈述是真实的信念。
Shelley clearly remembered Liz's reaction. Liz called me from the airport, sobbing. She wasn't so much pain because he didn't show up. She said, I can't believe it. I don't know what happened. I don't know what happened to him. I'm worried about him. I think something happened to him. But at the same time, there was an inkling within her that maybe this was a scam. I mean, I felt in her voice that she was starting to through her pain, through her tears, starting
雪莉清楚地记得莉兹的反应。莉兹从机场给我打电话，泣不成声。她不是因为他没出现而感到痛苦。她说，我不敢相信。我不知道发生了什么。我不知道他发生了什么事。我很担心他。我想他出事了。但与此同时，她内心有一种预感，也许这是一个骗局。我的意思是，我从她的声音中感觉到，她开始透过她的痛苦，透过她的泪水，开始
to see that it was possible that this was not real. As Liz sat in her car at the airport, the wall of certainty she had built around herself began to crack. She thought of the unopened emails her friends had written her. The links they had sent to FBI webpages and articles written by women cawned on dating sites. She thought about how Sergio always had an excuse for why they couldn't video chat. She checked into a hotel and did something she never thought she would do.
看到这可能是假的。当莉兹坐在机场的车里时，她为自己建立的确定性之墙开始破裂。她想到了朋友们写给她的未拆封的电子邮件。她们发送的FBI网页链接，以及约会网站上被骗女性写的文章。她想到了塞尔吉奥总是为为什么他们不能视频聊天找借口。她住进了一家酒店，做了一件她从未想过自己会做的事。
She called the FBI. And of course they tell you, don't call, you need to complete a form online. And I completed a form online and nothing happened, right? I mean, it's a form in somebody's desk and a stack of forms. Eventually, she tried to get some sleep. The next morning, I decided to try and call him again. And he picks up the phone.
她给FBI打了电话。当然，他们告诉你，别打电话，你需要在线填写表格。我在线填写了一份表格，什么也没发生，对吧？我的意思是，那只是某人桌子上的一堆表格中的一份。最终，她试图睡一会儿。第二天早上，我决定试着再给他打个电话。他接了电话。
And he says, Hi, what are you doing? And I said, what do you mean what am I doing? What the f*** I was, sorry, I was using foul language. I was at a control upset. He says, if you only knew what happened to me, you would not be talking to me this way. And he proceeds to tell me,
他说，嗨，你在做什么？我说，你什么意思，我在做什么？该死的，我，抱歉，我用了脏话。我当时情绪失控。他说，如果你知道我发生了什么，你就不会这样跟我说话了。然后他开始告诉我，
I was on my way to the airport when my ex-wife called me. And she told me that my son had been involved in unmoved accident. He died last night. They couldn't save his life. And I just, I'm just in disbelief. And he starts crying. I remember Liz calling me when she was at a hotel in Phoenix after Sergio had failed to show up at the airport. And she told me, I spoke to him, it's a horrible situation, his son was just killed in a car accident, and that's why he didn't come.
我正在去机场的路上，我的前妻给我打了电话。她告诉我我的儿子卷入了一场车祸。他昨晚去世了。他们没能救他的命。我只是，我只是不敢相信。他开始哭泣。我记得莉兹在塞尔吉奥没能出现在机场后，在凤凰城的一家酒店给我打电话。她告诉我，我和他谈过了，这是一个可怕的情况，他的儿子刚刚在车祸中丧生，这就是他没来的原因。
And I heard in her voice a transition from the sobbing earlier to being sucked back in to this idea of this man who she really wanted to be in a relationship with. In Leon's Festinger studies of cognitive dissonance, he found that challenging people's core beliefs often produced a boomerang effect. After wavering for a moment in the face of disconfirming evidence, people often returned to their core beliefs with even greater ferocity. The psychologist eventually came up with a list of conditions that typically produced cognitive dissonance. The first, of course, was that a person had to deeply believe something. The second was that the person commit to their belief by taking some kind of irreversible action, like sending someone a lot of money without the guarantee of reimbursement or sharing something deeply personal that left them vulnerable.
我从她的声音中听到了从早先的啜泣到被重新吸入这个想法的转变，这个她真心想与之建立关系的男人。在利昂·费斯廷格的认知失调研究中，他发现挑战人们的核心信念往往会产生回旋镖效应。在面对不确认的证据时犹豫片刻后，人们往往会以更大的猛烈程度回归他们的核心信念。这位心理学家最终列出了一系列通常产生认知失调的条件。第一个当然是，一个人必须深信某事。第二个是，这个人通过采取某种不可逆转的行动来承诺他们的信念，比如在没有报销保证的情况下给某人汇一大笔钱，或者分享一些让他们变得脆弱的极其私人的事情。
The third condition was that the belief needed to be specific and grounded in a possible reality. Liz's experience, meeting a soulmate on a dating site, is not an uncommon experience nowadays. Since the scenario is plausible, it feels believable. Watching from the outside, Shelley, Diedra and Liz's other friends could only look on helplessly. From where they stood, Liz had to choose between fiction and the facts.
第三个条件是，信念需要是具体的，并建立在可能的现实基础上。莉兹的经历，在约会网站上遇到灵魂伴侣，在当今并不是一种罕见的经历。由于这种情况是合理的，它感觉是可信的。从外部观察，雪莉、迪德拉和莉兹的其他朋友只能无助地看着。从她们的角度来看，莉兹必须在虚构和事实之间做出选择。
But Shelley realized that for Liz, the choice was much more painful. She was choosing not between lies and the truth, but between happiness and despair. I think she was so happy to be feeling these incredible feelings of love. I think she didn't want to let go of that. It was too good. It was simply too real to say that it could be anything other than the truth. And then in a master's stroke, Sergio made it virtually impossible for Liz to doubt him. He returned most of her money. I asked Liz what she felt like in that moment. I just felt exonerated. Why was I doubting this man? He just sent me most of the money and more will come. And I just felt everything's going to be okay. Did you feel at this point that some of the advice
但雪莉意识到，对莉兹来说，选择要痛苦得多。她选择的不是谎言和真相，而是幸福和绝望。我想她太高兴能感受到这些不可思议的爱意了。我想她不想放手。这太好了。说它不可能是真相，这简直太真实了。然后，在神来之笔中，塞尔吉奥让莉兹几乎不可能怀疑他。他退还了她大部分钱。我问莉兹那一刻她感觉如何。我只是感到被平反了。我为什么要怀疑这个男人？他刚刚把大部分钱寄给了我，更多的钱会来的。我只是觉得一切都会好起来的。你当时觉得一些建议
that your friends were giving you that in some ways it was misguided advice because clearly looked they were wrong. Yes, I was right. Sergio was real. It's an unusual situation. Life can be unusual. It's all for the best. It's okay. Liz's boomerang back to faith, deepened her commitment to Sergio. She felt embarrassed that she had ever doubted this kind man. She was upset with herself for being angry with him the day after his son was killed. So when Sergio asked her for another favor, Liz jumped at the chance to redeem herself. This time he requested she buy and send computers and cellphones to a relative of his in the United States. When I said I just mailed them computers, he said, good job, you thank you, well done.
你朋友给你的那些建议在某种程度上是误导，因为很明显，看，他们错了。是的，我是对的。塞尔吉奥是真实存在的。这是一种不同寻常的情况。生活有时就是不同寻常。一切都是为了最好的结果。没关系的。莉兹对信仰的回归加深了她对塞尔吉奥的承诺。她为自己曾经怀疑过这个善良的人感到尴尬。她对自己在他儿子去世后的第二天对他发火感到难过。所以当塞尔吉奥再次请求她帮忙时，莉兹毫不犹豫地抓住了这个弥补自己的机会。这一次，他要求她购买并寄送电脑和手机给他在美国的一位亲戚。当我告诉他我已经把电脑寄出去了，他说，干得好，谢谢你，做得好。
He gave me a lot of positive feedback that way. I did what he had asked me to do. I spent evenings and weekends doing a lot of this. Having a sense that it was all gonna be okay, that this was all in some way going to work out. Liz began to help Sergio without reservation. She offered both financial and emotional support. They talked about how difficult it was to be surrounded by memories of his son.
他给了我很多积极的反馈。我做了他要求我做的事。我花了很多个晚上和周末做这些事。心里有一种感觉，觉得一切都会好起来的，这一切在某种程度上都会解决的。莉兹开始毫无保留地帮助塞尔吉奥。她提供了经济和情感上的支持。他们谈论了被他儿子的记忆所包围是多么痛苦。
And then one day, Liz received a message that told her that all her faith in this man was going to be rewarded. Sergio says, I cannot live in Italy anymore. I need to come be with you. I want to move to America and try it out. Liz was ecstatic. She immediately began searching for apartments
然后有一天，莉兹收到了一条消息，告诉她，她对这个男人所有的信任都将得到回报。塞尔吉奥说，我不能再住在意大利了。我需要去和你在一起。我想搬到美国去试试。莉兹欣喜若狂。她立即开始寻找公寓
and found one in a neighborhood she really liked. She sent him a picture and asked him if she should sign a lease. He said, well, let's wait until I get there. Don't sign any leases now. She held off, slightly disappointed, but distracted herself by booking them a reservation at a luxury resort.
并找到了一个她非常喜欢的社区。她发了一张照片给他，问他是否应该签租约。他说，嗯，等我到了再说吧。现在先别签任何租约。她忍住了，虽然有点失望，但通过预订一家豪华度假村来分散自己的注意力。
Top of the line service in the most pristine and beautiful canyon in Sedona, dinner and champagne, chocolates. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. For a second time, Liz was preparing to pick up Sergio at the airport, and he wasn't just coming for a visit, he was looking into moving permanently to be with her. To calm her nerves on the drive to the airport, list up by a car wash.
在塞多纳最原始、最美丽的峡谷中提供顶级服务，晚餐、香槟、巧克力。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。莉兹第二次准备去机场接塞尔吉奥，他不仅仅是来探访的，他还在考虑永久搬来和她住在一起。为了在开车去机场的路上平复紧张的情绪，莉兹去洗了个车。
She wanted every last detail to be perfect for his arrival. She looked at her phone every few minutes, willing time to move faster. At one point, she felt her phone buzz and looked down to see a text from an unknown sender. It says, do you know Sergio Blabla, his last name? And I don't answer and he says, you need to know Sergio is scamming you. He's a scammer and he's out to destroy you. Liz quickly texted back. I said, who is this? The person typed out that he was an admiral in the US Navy.
她希望他到达时的每一个细节都完美无缺。她每隔几分钟就看一眼手机，希望时间过得快一点。突然，她感觉到手机震动，低头一看，是一条来自陌生号码的短信。上面写着，你认识塞尔吉奥·布拉布拉（他的姓氏）吗？我没有回复，他又说，你需要知道塞尔吉奥在骗你。他是个骗子，他要毁了你。莉兹迅速回信。我说，你是谁？那个人打字说他是美国海军的一名海军上将。
Liz asked to speak with him. After a few minutes, her phone rang. On the other end of the line was a gruff man with a sudden accent. He resided all the payments she had made to Sergio. And then he dropped the bombshell. He just starts telling me in very fast speech, I am finding that my retirement account has been broken into and Sergio has sent you money from my account and I want that money back.
莉兹要求和他通话。几分钟后，她的电话响了。电话那头是一个声音粗鲁、带着口音的男人。他列举了她付给塞尔吉奥的所有款项。然后他抛出了重磅炸弹。他开始用非常快的语速告诉我，我发现我的退休账户被入侵了，塞尔吉奥用我的账户给你汇了钱，我要把那笔钱要回来。
Liz felt her throat constrict. The man told her he was going to hold her responsible for the payment Sergio had made to her. But he also said he recognized that she was a fellow victim. And he said he was part of an intelligence team that was about to cat Sergio. He asked for her credit card number, so she could be reimbursed for the other payments she had made. At this point, I am sitting in my car just hysterical, you know, trying to talk to this person who is claiming to be someone who wants to help me. Flustered and frightened, Liz complied with a request.
莉兹感到喉咙发紧。那个人告诉她，他要让她对塞尔吉奥付给她的款项负责。但他同时也说，他意识到她也是受害者。他说他是情报小组的一员，正准备抓捕塞尔吉奥。他要求提供她的信用卡号码，这样她之前支付的其他款项就能得到补偿。此时，我正坐在车里歇斯底里，你知道，试图和这个声称要帮助我的人交谈。莉兹慌乱而恐惧，顺从了他的要求。
She read off her credit card number. Flustered and frightened, Liz complied with a request. She read off her credit card number. He asked her for the security code in the back of the credit card. She paused. She asked him if he had any ID. He said he could not share that information because it was classified. So I said, well, then I don't believe I'm talking to someone who's real. She refused to give him the security code.
她读出了她的信用卡号码。莉兹慌乱而恐惧，顺从了他的要求。她读出了她的信用卡号码。他问她信用卡背面的安全码。她停顿了一下。她问他是否有身份证件。他说他不能分享这些信息，因为那是机密。所以我说，好吧，那我不相信我在和一个真实的人说话。她拒绝给他安全码。
He threatened that he would press charges against her. Again, she asked him for some ID. He sent over a low quality photo of a military ID. It looked fake. Now I'm realizing this is not okay. My life is falling apart right in front of my eyes. Liz stared at the ID. Her hands shook.
他威胁说要起诉她。她再次要求他出示身份证件。他发来了一张低质量的军人身份证照片。看起来是假的。现在我意识到这不对劲。我的生活就在我眼前分崩离析。莉兹盯着那张身份证。她的手在颤抖。
Just then, a notification popped up on her phone. It was an email from Sergio. We had a voice actor read part of the email. Dear Lizzie, I am not real. I'm just a guy from Ghana. I'm really sorry that everything has to end up this way. I never intended to hurt you or make you fall into debt. At one point I wanted to confess to you and I wanted to ask you to not send any more money, but I could not because... I need to feed my family and take care of them. Please find a place in your heart to forgive me.
就在这时，她的手机弹出了一个通知。是塞尔吉奥发来的一封电子邮件。我们请了一位配音演员读了这封邮件的一部分。亲爱的莉兹，我不是真实存在的。我只是一个来自加纳的普通人。我真的很抱歉事情最终会变成这样。我从未想过要伤害你或让你陷入债务。有一次我想向你坦白，我想让你不要再寄钱了，但我不能，因为……我需要养活我的家人并照顾他们。请在你的心中找个地方原谅我。
I wish I could find a woman that will love me just like you. The way you love Sergio. And then he goes on and he explains to me in great detail what is going to happen. He said, someone will contact you, telling you that he knows everything about me.
我希望我能找到一个像你爱我一样爱我的女人。就像你爱塞尔吉奥那样。然后他继续解释，非常详细地告诉我接下来会发生什么。他说，会有人联系你，告诉你他对我的一切了如指掌。
They'll give you everything we've shared together to prove that they know me and they are trying to track me or help you recover your money back. But truly what they are trying to do is destroy your credit and destroy you. So please, for your own safety, don't have contact with them. I mean, he's actually trying to help me, this man who stole from me is now trying to warn me that this is happening. He could have just written nothing or he could have said, I'm a scammer, haha, bye. by, but instead he wrote these long letter that had the tones of a love letter to me and the tones of someone who really cared about me.
他们会给你我们分享过的一切，以证明他们了解我，他们正试图追踪我或帮助你追回你的钱。但实际上他们试图做的是破坏你的信用并毁掉你。所以为了你自己的安全，请不要和他们联系。我的意思是，他实际上是在试图帮助我，这个偷了我钱的人现在却在试图警告我正在发生的事情。他本可以什么都不写，或者说，我是个骗子，哈哈，再见。但他却写了这些长信，语气像情书，也像是一个真正关心我的人的语气。
It really is a very confusing email. I mean, I read it and I did not know what to make of it and I can only imagine what it must have felt like for you to read it. What goes through your head at that point, Liz? Well, I hate to say this, but it's really a confusing mixture of connection and hatred and disbelief, just a mix of what just happened, what is happening, am I dreaming?
这确实是一封非常令人困惑的邮件。我的意思是，我读了它，不知道该怎么理解，我只能想象你读到它时是什么感觉。那时候你脑子里在想什么，莉兹？嗯，我不想这么说，但这真的是一种连接感、仇恨和怀疑的混乱混合体，只是刚刚发生的事情、正在发生的事情的混合，我在做梦吗？
Liz sat in her car for a few hours. She tried to collect herself. Then, instead of heading to the romantic retreat in Sedona, she drove home. As the desert passed by, she slowly let the truth about the last few months of her life sink in. It was devastating. I mean, I'm still at a loss as to what to say.
莉兹在车里坐了几个小时。她试图让自己平静下来。然后，她没有前往塞多纳的浪漫度假地，而是开车回家了。当沙漠从窗外掠过时，她慢慢地让关于过去几个月生活的真相沉淀下来。这太令人崩溃了。我的意思是，我仍然不知道该说什么。
I actually didn't eat for five days. I made myself drink water. I could not stomach food. I was just in shock. I went to work, but I was useless. I cried. I called FBI again and I made a police report. Nothing made a difference.
我实际上五天没吃东西。我强迫自己喝水。我无法消化食物。我当时处于休克状态。我去上班了，但我什么也做不了。我哭了。我再次给联邦调查局打电话，并报了警。什么都没有改变。
I didn't know who to talk to. I didn't know what to do. What was the next step? How do I gain myself back? She started by calling her friends and confessing what had happened. She was so distraught and just barely able to get her words out, just sucking an air and hardly being able to get her words out.
我不知道该和谁谈。我不知道该怎么办。下一步是什么？我该如何找回自己？她开始给朋友打电话，坦白了发生的一切。她非常痛苦，几乎说不出话来，只是在吸气，几乎无法说出完整的话。
Just sucking an air and hardly being able to breathe. I was so worried about her. I just felt like, okay, it's over. She has realized what is happening to her. I just remember feeling, like all the air had just gone out of me and I was just in an incredible state of relief and a sense of, okay, now we can start working on her getting out of this and recovering
只是在吸气，几乎无法呼吸。我当时非常担心她。我只是觉得，好吧，结束了。她已经意识到发生了什么。我只记得那种感觉，好像我身上所有的空气都被抽干了，我处于一种难以置信的解脱状态，感觉到，好吧，现在我们可以开始帮助她摆脱困境并从中恢复了。
from it. Liz knew she had to untangle why she had refused to listen to her friend's concerns. She was filled with searing shame. Part of why I wanted to tell my story is that I want to continue working on forgiving myself because I'm not there yet. I have worse feelings towards myself than towards him. I feel I allowed someone who very possibly did need money to be clever enough and insightful and evil to do what he did. But I have more resentment towards myself because I allowed it to get out of hand. The pain less experienced as she confronted the truth
莉兹知道她必须理清为什么她拒绝听取朋友的担忧。她心中充满了强烈的羞耻感。我想要讲述我的故事的部分原因是我想要继续努力原谅自己，因为我还没做到。我对自己的感觉比对他还要糟糕。我觉得我允许了一个很可能确实需要钱的人，变得如此聪明、敏锐和邪恶，做出了他所做的事情。但我对自己有更多的怨恨，因为我让事情失控了。莉兹在面对真相时所经历的痛苦
helps explain why many people who believe deeply in comforting fictions never find their way back to reality. Dorothy Martin, Charles Lawhead and many of the other seekers never surrendered their belief in the guardians. Each time the flying saucers failed to show up, they quelled their dissonance by coming up with new ways to defend their delusions. Long after the chaotic Christmas caroling scene, Dorothy Martin continued to receive what she said were messages from the guardians. She would send these messages to her followers
有助于解释为什么许多深信令人安慰的虚构故事的人永远无法回到现实。多萝西·马丁、查尔斯·劳黑德和许多其他寻求者从未放弃对守护者的信仰。每当飞碟没有出现时，他们就会通过想出新的方法来捍卫自己的错觉来平息内心的失调。在混乱的圣诞颂歌场景发生很久之后，多萝西·马丁继续收到她所说的来自守护者的信息。她会把这些信息发送给她的追随者
by mail. Charles Lohead sold his home in Michigan and decided to travel the country, lecturing about his beliefs. One of the researchers who had infiltrated the group reported that he seemed highly confident that everything was still going according to plan. In May 1955, Charles Lawhead returned to Michigan. He had received word from a fellow believer that it was time. At long last, all his sacrifices were going to be repaid. He was going to be picked up by flying saucers.
通过邮件。查尔斯·劳黑德卖掉了他在密歇根州的房子，决定在全国各地旅行，宣讲他的信仰。其中一名潜入该团体的研究人员报告说，他似乎非常自信，一切仍在按计划进行。1955年5月，查尔斯·劳黑德回到了密歇根州。他从一位信徒那里得到消息，时候到了。终于，他所有的牺牲都将得到回报。他将被飞碟接走。
He was instructed to wait on the garage ramp of the largest hotel in the town where he had lived. All night long Charles Lawhead, his wife, his daughter, and another follower waited on the ramp, gazing up at the heavens. As Leon festering her and his colleagues wrote in their book about the Seekers, their faith was boundless, and their resistance to this confirmation sublime. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our voice actors, Thane Burton, Carol Schaffner, and Equate Thompson, and our Carolers, the Auto Family.
他被指示在他居住城镇最大的酒店的车库坡道上等待。整整一夜，查尔斯·劳黑德、他的妻子、他的女儿和另一名追随者都在坡道上等待，凝视着天空。正如莱昂·费斯廷格和他的同事在关于“寻求者”的书中所写的那样，他们的信仰是无限的，他们对这种证实的抵制是崇高的。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特姆·巴恩斯、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯汀·黄、瑞安·卡茨和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周特别感谢我们的配音演员塞恩·伯顿、卡罗尔·沙夫纳和伊奎特·汤普森，以及我们的颂歌演唱者奥托一家。
Our Ronsang heroes this week are Elliot Aronson and Carol Tavris. They are two researchers who worked with Leon Festinger. We reached out to Elliot and Carol as we were researching this episode, and they offered useful suggestions about university archives that might have information about Leon Festinger's work. Elliott and Carol are also the authors of a very fine book that explores the science of cognitive dissonance. It's called Mistakes Were Made, but Not By Me. Thank you, Elliott and Carol.
我们本周的英雄是埃利奥特·阿伦森和卡罗尔·塔夫里斯。他们是曾与莱昂·费斯廷格共事的研究人员。我们在研究这一集时联系了埃利奥特和卡罗尔，他们就可能包含莱昂·费斯廷格工作信息的大学档案提供了有用的建议。埃利奥特和卡罗尔也是一本非常优秀的书的作者，该书探讨了认知失调的科学。书名是《错误已经发生，但不是我做的》。谢谢你们，埃利奥特和卡罗尔。
We're always on the lookout for great personal stories for future hidden brain episodes. If you have a story about a powerful experience in your life, especially a story that has left you with more questions than answers, please record a short voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, Personal Story. If you enjoyed today's episode, please be sure to share it with two or three friends. This is a great episode to listen to as a group, maybe on a long walk. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们一直在寻找未来《隐藏的大脑》剧集的精彩个人故事。如果你有一个关于你生活中强大经历的故事，特别是一个让你留下更多问题而不是答案的故事，请在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录。发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org，主题行使用“个人故事”。如果你喜欢今天的剧集，请务必与两三位朋友分享。这是一集非常适合作为小组收听的节目，也许是在长途散步时。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。